the taliban is not the south of the
north vietnamese army it is not at all
comfortable it is extremely comparable
it turns out that when the united states
ends a war our opponents don't we'll be
back in there in six months in fact as
it turns out we might be back in there
inside of six hours after 20 long years
in afghanistan the united states is
pulling out we are not pulling out for a
good reason it would be one thing if
there was some actual strategy attached
to this or if the united states were
actually achieving some sort of sensible
goal the united states however is not
doing any of that the united states is
withdrawing from afghanistan at a time
when this is no longer among america's
endless wars in order for a war to be
considered endless you actually have to
be in a state of continual warfare the
united states currently has or did have
until joe biden announced to withdrawal
3 500 troops in afghanistan the last
combat casualties in the united states
from american soldiers in afghanistan
was on february 8th 2020. it is
currently august 2021
that is not an active combat zone you're
more likely to be killed as a cop in
chicago than you are to be killed as a
combat soldier in afghanistan if you're
an american right now okay but joe biden
decided he wanted a win and because he
wanted to win and i don't even know what
he thought the wind was going to be we
were going to pull out precipitously
from afghanistan now
i understand the argument that we were
never going to achieve our goal in
afghanistan if our goal was defined as
nation building this was never going to
be a thriving democracy it is literally
the most tribal place on earth there's
no history of democracy or liberality or
human rights
those things just
were not there until the united states
got there and so the idea that we were
going to graft western institutions onto
very inhospitable soil
that always seemed like a bit of a pipe
dream but there is still a rather
large-scale american interest in
afghanistan if you recall why we first
went there we didn't go there to build
democracy in afghanistan we went there
in order to deny al-qaeda a staging base
and because we had not done that in the
1990s al qaeda used taliban occupied
afghanistan as a staging base for 911
and having 3 500 troops
taking control of the kandahar air force
base for example and ensuring that the
united states had the ability to send
out drone strikes the ability to work
with the afghan military to stage
attacks on terror bases the ability to
train the afghan military and provide
them backup and weaponry if they were
going to take on potential threats to
the united states that was always the
primary goal again the goal was never
primarily to turn afghanistan into a
democracy the problem is over time
because politicians have a very
difficult time just expressing what
america's interest is in terms of
foreign policy
american politicians tend to speak in
high flown beautiful terms about the
rise of democracy and the rise of human
rights and all the rest of this but if
you make that your primary driver then
you do become the world's policeman and
people start to miss why we went into
afghanistan in the first place which is
that al qaeda killed 3 000 americans on
9 11 and we'd said to the taliban turn
over osama bin laden and they refused to
do so and so we deposed the dictators
there the taliban
we replaced them with the northern
alliance there was a sort of
proto-democracy happening there in other
words we let our failure with the
secondary goal of establishing a
thriving democracy in afghanistan
overtake our primary goal which is to
continue to provide a base of operations
against terrorists in afghanistan and so
now we are withdrawing for no
discernible purpose at all and the
immediate effect of this as it was
always destined to be is that the
taliban are rushing right back in and
taking over according to the associated
press today the taliban captured two
major afghan cities the country's second
and third largest after kabul and a
strategic provincial capital on thursday
further squeezing the embattled
government just weeks before the end of
the american military mission in
afghanistan remember joe biden for some
odd reason decided that he wanted to
withdraw all american troops by
september 11th which i don't even
understand the symbolism there what in
the hell is the symbolism there
the symbolism of here's the group of
people who harbored the people who
committed 911 we're gonna pull out on
the 20th anniversary of that date and
hand the place back to those people how
is that even a symbolic win
like who was the constituency for this
it's always been a promise that
politicians have made right obama made
the promise he was going to withdraw
from afghanistan then he increased
troops because it turns out being the
president comes with seeing the intel
reports and then donald trump said he
was going to pull out of afghanistan and
then necessity
meant that we had to keep troops in
afghanistan and then joe biden because
he's a dullard decided we're just gonna
go ahead with this and it doesn't matter
what comes next
which is completely short-sighted and i
don't even see the political calculus
here because the american people don't
tend to care about foreign policy until
the heads start coming off right that's
the point where we care about foreign
policy so america doesn't care about
what's going on in syria but if the
media start blanketing the tv with james
foley being beheaded in syria suddenly
the american people are deeply concerned
about what's happening in syria half a
million civilians can die in syria and
we won't give a damn but the minute that
an american gets beheaded suddenly we
want our troops on the ground doing
something about it
right if there is tape that comes out of
the yazidis being attacked by isis then
all of a sudden we say why can't we do
something about that see america is
good-hearted but only in short spurts so
i don't understand what biden even
thinks he is doing here because you know
what the next footage is going to be and
it's going to be a taliban fighters
beheading people
we'll be back in there in six months in
fact as it turns out we might be back in
there inside of six hours the united
states is gonna have to put thousands of
troops on the ground to evacuate the u.s
embassy in kabul
according to the associated press the
seizure of kandahar inherit marks the
biggest prizes yet for the taliban who
have taken 12 of afghanistan's 34
provincial capitals as part of a
week-long blitz the capture of the city
of ghazni meanwhile cuts off a crucial
highway linking the afghan capital kabul
with the country's southern provinces
all part of an insurgent push some 20
years after u.s and nato troops invaded
and ousted the taliban government
while kabul itself isn't under direct
threat yet the losses and the battles
elsewhere further tighten the grip of a
resurgent taliban who are estimated to
now hold over two-thirds of the country
and continue to press their offensive
with securedly rapid
with security rapidly deteriorating the
united states plans to send in 3 000
troops to help evacuate some personnel
from the u.s embassy in kabul so just to
get this straight we are withdrawing 3
500 troops so we can send back in 3 000
troops to evacuate the us embassy in
kabul
and then when the videos hit the tv of
all the women being lined up and shot by
the taliban which is undoubtedly the
next thing that is going to hit your tv
then presumably we'll be sending in
another 3 000 troops again
this is just a replay of barack obama's
decision that we're going to pull all
troops out of iraq and then isis took
over and voila we were back in iraq
it turns out when the united states ends
a war our opponents don't that is not
how wars typically end if you declare
that you have lost your opponent simply
fills the vacuum
according to the associated press
thousands of afghans have fled their
homes amid fears the taliban will again
impose a brutal oppressive government
all but eliminating women's rights and
conducting public amputations at
stonings and executions peace talks in
qatar remain stalled though diplomats
met throughout the day
the latest u.s military intelligence
assessment suggests kabul could come
under insurgent pressure within 30 days
and that if current trends hold the
taliban could gain full control of the
country within a few months the afghan
government may eventually be forced to
pull back to defend the capital in just
a few other cities in the coming days if
the taliban keep up their momentum
the onslaught represents a stunning
collapse of afghan forces and renews
questions about where the over 830
billion dollars spent by the us defense
department on fighting training those
troops and reconstruction efforts went
especially as taliban fighters ride on
american-made humvees and pickup trucks
with the m16s slung over their shoulders
just delightful delightful stuff afghan
lawmaker samin barkazai
announced the city's fall saying some
officials there had escaped witnesses
described seeing taliban fighters once
detained at harrah's prison now moving
freely on the streets
in kandahar the taliban sees the
governor's office and other buildings
witnesses said the governor and other
officials fled the onslaught catching a
flight to kabul they declined to be
named publicly because the defeat has
yet to be acknowledged by the government
the taliban then opened up all the
prisons and let out all of the taliban
fighters who were there
ghazni provincial council member
amanullah khamrani alleged the
provincial governor and police chief
made a deal with the taliban to flee
after surrendering taliban video and
photos reported to show the governor's
convoy freely passing by insurgents as
part of the deal the afghan interior
ministry spokesperson
stanek's eye later said the governor and
his deputies had been arrested over that
alleged deal the officials could not be
immediately reached for comment
so this is a full-scale disaster area
the usa air force b-52 bombers f-15
fighter jets drones and other aircrafts
were involved in fighting across the
country so for all the talk about how we
weren't involved in the fighting anymore
it turns out that we are involved in the
fighting we're just now losing
so well done everybody
also nbc news is acknowledging that al
qaeda is rushing back in who could have
predicted this except for every single
sentient human being
of which joe biden doesn't belong in
that cadre he's not a sentient human
being any longer he is a house plant but
reality remains reality according to nbc
news with the taliban steamrolling
across afghanistan u.s defense officials
are concerned a taliban takeover of the
country will allow al-qaeda to rebuild
and consolidate creating security
concerns well outside afghan borders
nearly 20 years after it planned the
september 11th attack from afghanistan
al-qaeda has a diminished presence in
the country senior officials say it's
only two or three hundred members or as
barack obama might say it's the jv squad
until it's not the jv squad anymore one
of the officials said they're not really
very large or what we would consider a
capable contingent but the security
vacuum left by the withdrawal of u.s
military forces could create an opening
for al-qaeda and other terrorist groups
to reorganize the official say
if the taliban take over the government
intelligence about al-qaeda is likely to
become even scarcer
and while the us will still maintain
authority to strike al-qaeda targets in
afghanistan there's no us presence on
the ground no no air force base which
means we have to use neighboring
countries to base our air force if we
decide that we want to launch some
strikes
according to marine general frank
mckenzie he said what we're here to do
is prevent al-qaeda and isis from being
able to reconstitute in the ungoverned
spaces generally of eastern afghanistan
and be able to plot attacks against our
homeland that threat is still here today
he says if the pressure comes off i
believe they're going to regenerate i
think it's only a matter of time before
we see them assert themselves and begin
to plan attacks against our homeland and
of course that would be the predictable
result remember september 11th was the
outgrowth of the united states
unwillingness to take on al-qaeda after
the uss cold bombing after the bombings
of the american embassies in kenya and
tanzania you remember that bro that that
osama bin laden specifically said that
the united states was a paper target a
paper tiger and so the idea was that kid
hit us over and over and over again we
hadn't done anything so obviously we
wouldn't do anything if he hit our
towers and if he hit the pentagon
and then we kind of shocked him because
we actually did quite quite a lot but it
turns out that when you surrender
territory to some of the worst people on
earth they don't take that as you just
want peace they take that as you are
weak and you are foolish and then they
come after you
there's this sort of wishful thinking
that goes into so much of our foreign
policy these days that if we just
do the things that we want to do
everybody else will just fall into line
that is crazy
by the way the chances right now that
the united states embassy ends up
falling to the taliban really really
high maybe we avoid these sort of
insane imagery of the fall of saigon
where people are attempting to climb
onto helicopters but that will only be
because we station 3 000 marines outside
the us embassy while we evacuate the
place and then we leave an empty
building for the taliban to dance inside
of
joe biden says you don't see us
helicoptering people off roofs well
i have a feeling that we're going to see
something very similar do you see any
parallels between this withdrawal and
what happened in vietnam with some
people feeling none whatsoever
zero what you had is you had entire
brigades breaking through the gates of
our embassy
six if i'm not mistaken
the taliban is not the south of the
north vietnamese army
they're not they're not remotely
comparable in terms of capability
there's going to be no circumstance
where you see people being lifted off
the roof
of a
embassy in the of the united states from
afghanistan it is not at all comparable
um it is extremely comparable what do
you mean they don't have the same
capabilities you mean the capabilities
that ho chi minh army had when they
invaded south vietnam and then took the
capital you mean exactly the same thing
the taliban are doing exactly right now
in what sense is this any different
like oh really
is there any difference at all it's
exactly the same thing we were achieving
many of our objectives in afghanistan
mainly the objective to maintain a base
of operations with which to fight
terrorism just as we had achieved many
of our objectives in south vietnam
and then political actors decided that
surrender was preferable to any form of
success and so they just pulled out
precipitously while proclaiming victory
it's insane
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show if you did go ahead and
hit that subscribe button so you stay up
to date with all our future content